If you keep on following data dependencies and control dependencies
starting from a given statement,
the set of statements that you get,
that is, the set of statements that could have possibly influenced the statement in question,
is also called a program slice, also called backward slice
starting from statement, contains all of the statements
that the statement S in question would transitively depend upon.
You obtain a backward slice by starting with a statement S,
and then following all the dependencies until you have reached a fixed point.
The interesting thing about slices is
that anything that is not in the slice cannot have influenced the stage at the statement S
or whether S is being executed or not.
Therefore, the slice can act as a filter.
Let me illustrate this by an example.
As an example, let's take a look at the statement, "tag is true".
This is our statement S.
Now, let's see what's all contained in the slice of tag.
First of all, there is no direct data dependency because no variable is being read in here.
However, this is control dependent on this F condition.
This if condition, again, is dependent on the character C, so this is also part of the backward slice,
and this condition up here reads from the variable S, which is passed as a parameter up here,
so this is also part of the backward slice.
Now let's go to quote.
Where does quote come from?
It is being initialized up here and set down here,
so we end up in the place where quote is being set.
Now, can you keep on doing this?
Completing the backward slice of S?
One by one, check all statements that are part of the backward slice.